How long have you been doing this?
I mean like for TV, for animal planet. Uh,
three years I guess,
but to go on x.
The reason I got into that and doing
it for TV is because I've been doing it
like my whole life. I grew up in
Zimbabwe. My mom was a bush pilot,
so when we weren't on Safari,
she was like flying us these remote
place in the middle of Bush and we were
going out on safari and like, as long as
I can remember, this has been what I do
now. When you go on Safari, you and those
open jeeps walking safaris. Whoa. Yeah.
What are you doing?
Uh, we take a four, five, eight and
elephant gun. Put it on your shoulder.
Walking Safari. God Damn Man. Only during
the day, right. CanNot move at night.
And what do you do when you're confronted?
Okay.
I mean, I've had some pretty close
calls. Uh, my wife Jess is here with me.
I saved her from a hippo.
Oh yeah. We've had some
pretty close calls. Fuck man.
One of my scariest pictures
I ever saw was this guy,
this African guy running down the street
and a hippo is chasing them and you
look at the size of the hippo and you're
like, good Christ. That thing is huge
there, Joe. They're the
scariest animals on earth,
like interacting with the
hippopotamus there. So erratic.
They're so unpredictable. If they
feel threatened at all, I mean, yeah,
they're just, this video is fucking
bananas. Oh yeah. This guy's on a row,
a motor boat, and the hippo is
swimming after him like a torpedo.
So this is where I'm from. This
is in Bob Way. Really? Yeah.
So it was this common
that they swim that fast.
They can move.
I mean this,
that this is uncommon to have one chase
the boat and come that close. But uh,
fucking big it is, man. Yeah.
So when you've had these close encounters,
what do you do? You shoot at the air,
shoot at the ground,
scare him away.
Fortunately I've,
I've never had to put an animal down,
but I know people that have,
does your picture look at? That's
it. That's the one. What in the fuck,
how fast is that big bastard run?
Uh, I don't know. You'd have
to look up the exact speed,
but definitely at top speed.
Definitely faster than humans.
But they don't have the maneuverability,
you know,
you can kind of duck and dodge behind.
They're just don't run in a straight line.
Exactly. Exactly. Fuck that. 20 miles.
Miles 19 yeah. Yeah.
What does a person run?
A Rhino runs 31 Jesus Christ.
Jesus.
A fucking Cheetah convert 75 miles an
hour. I thought it was like 50. Ah,
fuck yeah.
Stephanie,
five crocodiles almost as fast as
the fucking hippo. Yeah, they're,
they're odd miles an hour for a croc.
Fuck that.
Let's be for sprinters around 2122 maybe.
That's a stain.
Yeah. That's also a sprinter.
[inaudible] sprinter,
doughy white guy like us.
Fuck Jesus Christ.
So you just,
if you're chased by a hippo,
is there a move that you do?
Do you just have to go left and right
and Zigzag? Yeah, maneuverability get.
So like when we got chased,
we got behind a termite mound and then
it kept going straight. Like, you know,
hiding behind termites now thinks
that safety like termites. Oh my God,
dude,
that's so crazy.